[Music]
sorry father
hello my name is Warren I'm an Internet
source this is my very first talk so
today I want to talk about programming
languages migrations on github so I'm
sure everybody here as well at least
once as even thought doing a you know an
obscure project well I could do the job
with this programming language but why
not switching to another one so here we
want to answer the following question
which is how strong are the flows of
developers from a language to another
one you can read my presentation or on
your device if you want to click the
links or zoom the visuals it's also
available on my github bio so I'm
working currently at source in Spain and
my background is mostly mathematics I
studied physics and moved to
optimization and because I love math and
I couldn't Ayten
my company is called source it's based
in Madrid it's about 20 people and we
are fetching all repositories from Gita
bit pocket and we we aim at doing our
source code on top of this code so that
we need to turn this source code into HD
and and then we can do machine learning
on top of it so we it's been 2 years we
developed the source engine so that we
can allow developers to use our power
technology and it includes several tools
like Sergio Gate bubble fish etc I
invite you to take a look at them about
the story of programming languages so
everything started from this blog post
from Eric Burnett soon they convicted of
why we move from a language x2 language
Greg well where Eric tried to quantify
the number of Google queries you know on
Stack Overflow of people said okay move
from Scala to Java etc and he build a
matrix and he concluded that go was the
most popular language based on Google
queries so when sourced opened the data
set of distribution repositories last
year I thought we could take a look at
this issue of popularity of languages
but not based on Google queries but
based on real sus chord which is
repositories so well how would data set
just few figures it is 4.5 million get
abusers nearly four hundred different
languages and in total it stands for ten
terabytes of code well if you take a
look at a sample of this data set it's a
user a github user
I found it convenient to take a look at
each github user with that kind of Gantt
chart so this is a guy that coded from
2012 to 2015 and we see that he fell he
mainly coded in Scala but he tried to
code something in 2012 in go but didn't
really get along with this language
because then he coded a big project in
Java and finally in markdown so seeing
well this is the history of the language
is used by this guy and here I just
wanted to notice that it would be
completely nonsense to say that okay the
guy in 2014
moved from Java to markdown we can say
this because we can compare languages
that are not comparable
they don't they don't have the same
purpose you know so here's a huge
assumption I had to make it is that well
first we focus on transition of
languages between 2000 and 2015
well that makes sense 2015 because
that's the end of my data set and but I
choose to focus on 20 comparable
programming languages well and I decided
to exclude JavaScript for several
reasons so you might be angry at me
because of this I don't know but the
thing is that javascript was everywhere
on every account of every developer on
github so it it's absorbed completely
the study and furthermore like if you're
dealing with JavaScript in the front end
you're kind of stuck to it anyway so
there's no point of moving from
JavaScript to another language and if
you use ekat in the backend
it is often refers that node and however
the territorial team couldn't make the
difference between those two languages
so well-well quickly the data set
includes hello world projects you know
whatever size projects and you agree
with me that code coding such a little
script wouldn't count for moving from a
language to another one so I can't ice
the data set this is in orange the the
distribution of contributions on github
per size and the blue curve is the key
approximation so if you just divide the
area under the curve into ten same areas
you can say that okay the first area
it's like the contributions equals to
zero etc and so it makes the study
clearer in terms of noise removal well
here we need to we need to compare we
need to find a distance to measure the
transition of a developer between
languages so this is how I represented
it you can see two vectors here the this
is the random github user and you have
on the Left the vector of his
contributions in 2014 and on the left
and the right the one in 2015 so and the
values of the node are the number of
bytes coding coded in that language so
here you have two distribution and you
want to compare it so you need to have a
distance and well in the literature you
can find many different distances like
simply the fqdn distance but i choose to
use linear programming here to compare
those two languages because well because
I love optimization and because more in
general linear up to linear programming
is very fast to compute so it was a good
choice here
it consists in introducing flows between
those two distributions and if you see
those values in terms of amount of time
dedicated in a language you want to find
the minimum cost flow of this problem
this problem is called it's a general
transportation problem and I used the
smallest distance implementation in the
P IMG package this is the the
mathematical formulation of the
transportation problem behind what we
just saw so we just want to minimize the
sum of the flows which is the X here and
C is just the cost of the flow but we
assume that we set all the cost to one
because we didn't want to make
assumptions in how our problems and the
two constraints here it's it's just
usual transportation constraints where
we would like to say that we need to
satisfy the demand which was on the
right and we need to we can't exceed the
supply which was on the left of course
the flows are positive and there is a
solution to the problem because of this
hypothesis we have this because we have
normalized the the histograms so it's
just equal to 1 so solving this we have
at the end of flow matrix per user per
pair of consecutive here and if you sum
everything you have this matrix so well
how to read it well it's a bit hard to
see but for example here you have Python
and the lighter it is this the stronger
is the value so you can see of course
that a lot of people move from C++ to
see from I don't know
from Python to Java here etc and the
diagonal would mean that a lot of people
stick to this language so it's a bit
hard to to understand what's happening
here so there is a little of work here
because our main question was we wanted
to answer we wanted to find how the
probability that a developer moved from
a language to another one so here we are
looking for the importance of the
languages you can say importance you can
say popularity but this is the main
thing behind it it's called the
centrality measure I'm sure you've heard
about this it's the kind of measure like
you you want to compute when you want to
know in for example the Facebook network
when you want to find the most important
guy in the network which has who has the
most influence you know we are doing
exactly the same thing with languages
and the popularity is we're going to
reach it computing the eigenvector
centrality so we are looking for an
eigenvector
there are several algorithms to find
them but we have to work on the metrics
a little bit so mainly there is three
steps the metrics have has to be
stochastic a cyclic and irreducible so
very briefly we make the previous blue
matrix stochastic by normalizing the
rows so we have probably probabilities
now and because all the values in the
matrix were strictly positive the
matches the matrix was irreducible you
know you had you you had not like some
kind of spider traps
I don't know people moving from Lua to
closer and closer to Lua and never to
other languages you don't have this
because all the values are positive so
you always have a way to reach language
from an from another one and this
theorem the apparent revenues just said
that because the values are positive we
are looking for the dominant eigen
vector which means the eigenvector
associated with the highest eigen value
which is 1 so we miss the way that the
matrix should be a cyclic and this kind
of matrix has already been I mean people
at Google worked on it and Larry and
Sergey find a nice trick to make the
matrix suitable for algorithms it's
called the this approach is called page
rank and basically it's just updating
the transition matrix which is P like
this where bed beta is the called random
work factor and doing this you you have
only positive values in in your matrix
geometric state stochastic and you have
the a sickly city of the matrix so now
we are fine to apply the algorithm to to
have the eigenvector this algorithm of I
choose power iteration because it's the
it's damn simple you just have to
multiply a vector random one by the
matrix again and again until convergence
and you have convergence because you
have these three properties
at the end you obtain a nice vector
which is the stationary distribution of
our Markovian process of moving from a
language to another one okay so in few
words it is the popularity this is how a
vector and the highest value was for
Python because and on the right I just
put the the amount of the relative
amount of source code so that you can
understand you can compare you know like
for example PHP a lot of projects are
coded in PHP in on Gita but its
popularity is not so high it's as high
as a Ruby whereas the source code is 2.5
well well I'm not going to check it that
a guy just send me the statistic annual
statistic of Gaeta this morning and you
can see that the ranking is almost the
same
you just have JavaScript on the top
because they didn't exclude it well if
you take how a former blue matrix you
you did all we have talked about like
normalizing the rows removing the
diagonal and sorting the metrics by our
popularity vector you obtained this and
so this is the same way of reading it
like you can see that for example let's
take I don't know
Jupiter notebook people coding in in
this environment are most likely to move
to Python I don't see the probability
but it might be something like 60% so it
makes a lot of sense and you can take
you can spend like days and and weeks
just looking at this matrix like you
have the strong relationship between
Objective C and Swift
which makes also sense same thing with
Scala and Java where it where is Java
Scala and Java here
etc and you see that for example
numerical languages like our Fortran
I don't know MATLAB they are most likely
to people coding in that language almost
likely to move to Pato
well to obtain the blue matrix I sum all
the years but if I look at the this
dominant eigen vector sequentially year
per year I could plot the evolution of
this dominant eigen vector which is this
stack of a plot so mainly the you know
the the the eigenvector with 70% for
python it's this one and i plot the
others so that you can feel the
evolution of the popularity of languages
from 2000 to 2015
so this is not an absolute study if you
have to stay to keep in mind that it is
related to the choice of languages I
choose at the beginning but if you
compare those 20 languages you obtained
this so well you can just take a look at
it sequentially like I don't know you
can see that C and C++ are going well
less popular but it's not really that
because a lot of and huge amount of code
is here so it's just that people started
to to code even more starting in 2010 so
it's just related popularity but if you
take a look at for example objective say
here this date 2014 it's when Apple
announced that people should switch from
Objective C to Swift because we've
started here and you can see that the
the layer of Swift takes the place of
Objective C and this is the the way of
renegade you can see that pearlies
well I don't want to fight with
recorders but their language is doing
very bad in terms of popularity seeing
this brown and python seems to be the
big winner here but I didn't know I was
talking to PETA
well well to finish this is few other
study we made at source the first one
just the first one is the my projects
I'm doing right now I'm developing a
model to to predicts your next comment
you're going to write in your shell
based on your own history it's based on
sequence to sequence learning and I hope
people would use it pretty soon and this
is a my contacts and above all the
contacts of my startup source that is a
highly looking for people as we are
growing really fast
well thank you
[Applause]
you